something horrible is happening there's
a Sriracha shortage so is artificial
intelligence to write me the closest
recipe possible to the secret Sriracha
recipe and this is what it came up with
the only info currently known about the
secret Sriracha recipe is that it
contains red jalapeno peppers garlic
sugar salt and distilled vinegar this AI
recipe also adds tomato paste and fish
sauce so I'm very intrigued to see if
these are in fact the secret ingredients
I blitzed everything together until I go
to paste and cooked it for about 15
minutes and then once it cooled down I
put it in a little sauce container then
I asked my boyfriend to do a blind taste
test to see if he could guess the
difference
okay
sriracha homemade dupe no
I do feel like I kind of like the dupe
better
so this one
saltier than this one but delicious